[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
all right all right all right okay so
we're due for home team podcast today we
haven't had one for a minute uh I think
the last time we did it it was a year
ago 2022. just so you know yes sir it's
been a long time it's been a while man
very long time anyways it's good to have
uh Biz doc Vincent or Shawna my man Adam
sauce here and believe AKA Rob in the
house as well we got a lot of topics to
cover yesterday's podcast obviously with
Neil deGrasse Tyson was great some of
the clips are some people are saying
it's not getting the views and all this
stuff I think one of the clips this one
here was getting 60 000 views per hour
and we're looking at it a day later on
Creative Studios it's missing 600 000
views not sure why but if you look at
this clip it's got 17 000 likes let's
see how many comments it's got comments
comments 27
000 comments it's got and on Twitter on
Facebook on my DMs email text it doesn't
matter where it is I've never got this
many clips and text messages about an
interview outside of Tate outside of
Sami outside of Kobe I'm gonna put it
like this has got to be a top ten more
than coffee no no not Kobe I said
outside
it's a top ten word but the views for
whatever reason when we look at the
clips it just goes Flatline and it shows
now this morning in the first eight
hours that only got 140 views again we
don't know why we're not speculating
we're just stating facts and data and
maybe it's algorithm issues on YouTube
no I'm not being paranoid about it it's
just data data and he said you got to
pay attention to daytime we're a date
again I was watching when you posted it
hit 14
000 in four minutes and I was like okay
this is going it is what it is if you
haven't watched it I highly recommend
anything inappropriate oh just I'm just
gonna say it was a great interview you
guys had a spirited conversation about
a certain thing that people may or may
not have taken during a certain period
or a period of time 70s 80s yeah you
know early 2020s it is what it is yeah
but I think more than anything we've
realized that certain companies certain
social media companies we don't know
don't like certain conversations I'm
ready to light up a cigar right now on
the podcast and just have a cigar and
have a conversation with you guys but we
don't want the sprinklers to come up and
get robbed audio problems we got a lot
of topics to get into here's the topic
so we've got like Rogan or a cigar like
Elon
bizdoc what do you play I told you Tom's
an animal
you don't believe me Tom's Got Game
Tom's going to write a book one day on
dating relationship and flirting and
that thing's gonna be a bestseller okay
in Silicon Valley
turns love doc yeah that's what it is a
love doc you're the love doctor
topics Microsoft investment into Chad
gbt's Creator maybe this smartest One
Billion Auto ever spent we'll talk about
that Fed ex-fed chair Alan Greenspan
sees a U.S recession as most likely
outcome most Americans turning to credit
cards to cover basic expenses as
inflation rages Tom's got some feedback
on that uh-oh Chinese billionaire Jack
ma to relinquish control of ant group
FTC says proposal to ban non-compete
clauses could boost pay by 300 billion
dollars a year a lot of this non-compete
is mainly California
Rolls-Royce had a record-breaking year
literally the biggest year ever they had
we'll talk about what that is
America's aggressive chip strategy
forces China into a corner McDonald's
former CEO Greece toupee ready
53 million dollars in SEC sediment this
is CEO Kevin McCarthy elected the
speaker of the house ending days of
Republican chaos and Division in
Washington we'll cover that I know Adam
you got some thoughts on that uh let's
see what else we got the secret to Ron
desantis's success ignore Donald Trump
and attack business instead so Bloomberg
story we'll cover that uh photos of
videos of Chaos in Brazil saying very
similar situation with Bolson era as it
was in the uh DC just a couple years ago
Elon Musk confronts Adam Schiff about
his efforts to pressure Twitter to
silence critics and journalists Federal
Regulators investigating musk's Tesla
full-serving driving tweet I'm sure he's
going to be investigated for a lot of
different things since he's pushing the
envelope biting towards El Paso border
sites uh Vinnie I know you got some
thoughts on that yeah MB NBC exec regret
paying Jimmy Fallon 80 million dollar
contract extension as Fox News Greg
Gutfeld beats tonight's shown ratings
this is Raider online story we got a
campaign to re-educate Jordan Peterson
social media created a generation of
weekend kids threatening American
culture and capitalism NYU business
school professor says in wsj Wall Street
Journal op-ed and maybe a couple other
things here that we have story wise but
Tom let's get right into the economy
with the story about credit card so if
you want to go to page four we have a
story about credit cards most Americans
turning to
um credit cards to pay expenses as
inflation rages as inflation continues
to erode purchase and power more
Americans are relying on credit cards to
pay basic expenses according to the
Census Bureau in December over 35
households use credit cards or loans to
pay for expenses in the past week up 32
percent in November 21 from April of
2021 interest rates on credit cards are
currently at high levels with the
average APR setting a new record damn is
that true 19.14 last week according to
bankrate.com if people carry debt to
cover Rising prices they could end up
paying more in the long run as interest
charges accrue credit card balance has
increased by more than 15 percent year
on year in November the largest increase
in over 20 years according to New York
fed survey Tom what are your thoughts on
this we've been talking about this on
the pbd podcast over the last couple
months said as those interest rates goes
up that the banks would raise the
interest rates on credit cards and raise
they did and additionally you've got
consumers with wage stagnation are
turning to the credit card to pay for
things and we saw some travel going down
uh certainly people aren't going to be
paying to go on Southwest Airlines
anytime soon and you had uh electronics
had a bummer Christmas you saw that like
big uh you know PlayStations big screen
TVs and electronics had a bum Christmas
why was that well it's because inflation
on core food stuff and we're also a
story in here about the uh we're at
all-time high on food costs that has
forced people to use the only place they
could get a raise to cover is artificial
and that's from their credit card the
other side of this it's very interesting
is that the um this is directly related
to housing people are right now rents
are edging up and the the housing prices
are not dropping as fast so those same
consumers are kind of stuck they can't
make a change in their housing costs
like maybe I'll sell my house and Lease
something for a year let prices come
down it's all interrelated here the
pinch is coming and what's even worse is
we're seeing layoffs are going to come
February March April we're going to see
layoffs pick up so you got consumers
that are already pinched by inflation
using their credit card layoffs are
coming so everybody that says there's
not a recession this year it's just not
paying attention you know this it's a
hurricane coming ashore and we can talk
more about housing in a little bit
what's going on there but this is huge
Pat this is this is people are being
pinched and we are spinning it in the
mainstream media and we are not talking
about the kind of things that need to to
help the American Consumer Tom why don't
you go into housing so what do you see
happening with housing what's very
interesting right now what's going on so
the because the interest rates are so
high
when you put your house on the market
it's hard to find the buyers and the
housing is sitting there longer so
people are not putting that inventory
out there if the inventory was out there
the prices would go down because there's
more houses out there buyers who could
afford the interest rate even though
it's six seven percent actually and
eight percent if your credit's not good
um and so the inventory right now is
staying steady so prices are flat when
people say oh that's great yeah except
if you look at the number of
transactions transactions aren't
happening look at the number of new
mortgages the number of transactions
transactions are down 80 percent last
year 70 last year depending on the
market transactions are down 70 yeah if
you take a look at like refi go go look
at refi's year over year I think refi's
year over year are almost zero and if
you're good at real estate transactions
now Miami may be a little bit better
where we are here
um but transactions in the housing
market
houses aren't selling and the home
builders you could Toll Brothers uh
Lanier and out there
um
here Rob I'm sending you a link go to
this one
go to this website here that's the rates
I want you to go to this website it
shows the refinance application the
level index the numbers are unbelievable
what it is look at that zoom in a little
bit they're there zero rear 86.2 percent
refinancing is down yeah but by the way
but let me let me just put put it to you
this way for a loan officer this is what
that means if you were making a hundred
grand a month a year ago you're making
thirteen thousand eight hundred dollars
and you're probably buying groceries
with your credit card if you were a loan
officer a year ago making 10 grand a
month you're making a thousand three
hundred and eighty dollars a month
returning your S-Class and you're
selling your watches you bought for
fifteen thousand dollars for forty two
hundred dollars and you just moved in
with your mom yeah Mom and Dad are
loving that yeah this is no joke by the
way this is a real number that's a scary
week over week is 30 yep so when people
say what you're hearing in media housing
prices are steady well yeah but you
can't sell it right the number one thing
and help me out here Adam you know a lot
of people in real estate and sauce talks
money you've got a lot of topics on this
that when you're accepting an offer for
your home the number one thing you want
is certainty of clothes you want to
evaluate the buyer is the down payment
real or was it loaned by somebody and
now the mortgage lender is going to
freak out and say wait wait we can't do
that you can't be using borrowed money
to make a down payment it's certainty a
close right it's appraisal it's
everything that goes through that right
now certainty of close is low because
who who can afford the seven percent
mortgage and what would I do once I sold
my house and you're seeing it in a
transaction so the as soon as the
inventory gets out there housing prices
are going to go down what what I and
upad you've been saying this too by the
end of this year and I'm still holding
to my third quarter and third quarter
fed will drop rates for the first time
probably early third quarter Fourth of
July Maybe
fed drops rates for the first time
little more inventory comes out housing
prices come down and that part of the
market moves but in the meantime you
know this and credit cards and the
interest rates on the credit cards
consumers are in for a very very rough
ride right now and if you're in a
marginalized um uh industry you're
probably also looking at layoffs there's
a recession coming and so everybody said
oh it was a soft landing and all this we
haven't landed yet we haven't landed at
all we're still in the on the recession
and and
we're the clicking stage of the roller
coaster click click click click click
click click they haven't dropped yet
everybody's gonna everybody's gonna
raise their hands and scream at the same
time I want to read this to you so it
says the US's chance of dodging a
recession or growing given layoffs
remain low top Moody economists okay he
says uh this is Page Three he says that
maybe we're gonna get past this
recession and it won't even happen uh
the US economy May avoid a recession in
20 2023 according to Mark Zandy the top
Economist at Moody's Analytics he
pointed to Friday's job report which
showed average hourly earnings Rising by
lower than expected 0.3 percent on
unemployment rate falling
to three and a half percent as evidence
that companies are not laying off
workers and he added that the wage
inflation falling while employment
remains high so it's also a good sign
for the US economy as people and jobs
are likely to spend more and save less
feeding into the economic growth many
companies have put in place short-term
thinking short-term hiring freezes and
reduce uh workers overall hours in an
effort to lower spending so that's what
he's saying and in Greenspan is saying
Economist Alan Greenspan and William
Dudley have both warned that a recession
is likely coming this year Greenspan
former Federal Reserve chairman stated
that a recession is the most likely
outcome while Dudley former New York
Federal Reserve president said that U.S
recession is likely due to the Federal
Reserve rate hikes Daryl Cronk Chief
investment officer for wealth and
Investment Management agreed that
Greenspan's prediction and argued that
recession is the likely outcome due to
the combination of tightening money
supply and a strong U.S dollar and
falling Bank Reserves however Cronk
disputed Dudley's argument that Federal
Reserve red hikes are the sole cost of
potential recession so here's here's a
question I'm on this page I'm with Chris
Brown so but why so so but this other
person is making a point saying hey
job it's not as bad as you think it is
Wages haven't dropped unemployment
dropped to three and a half percent it's
not just going to be a soft lending we
may even skip it who who has a better
argument I think respect does because I
think you know The Moody side yeah I I
think when you only look at the job side
of it you don't see the capability of
the consumer and you don't see what's
happening to Consumers own spending the
credit cards he is guessing
Moody's is guessing in an analytical way
I mean using analytics I mean they're
making a guess that oh well we've added
223 000 jobs and and we got all these
our earnings writing 0.3 of a percent
how does he even with the straight face
look in the camera and say well you know
earnings have risen 0.3 of a percent
from November when you're talking about
seven eight percent annual inflation and
we got statistics what's going on in
credit cards credit cards are more
expensive than ever and the banks are
saying hey we're looking at balances or
big those are hard data points so okay
you kept your job jobs are flat and
everything but inflation is still up and
how are you making up the difference and
we just talked about what's happening to
the entire mortgage and home buying
industry you know I I don't I don't know
I think if you just look at macro jobs I
I don't think so whereas the FED looks
at the data points of the sectors and
consumer spending and things so I tend
to be on the page of Allen and I tend to
look at like the hard data consumers
right now are not having easy time of it
hard data we didn't have a crazy TV
Christmas I mean we didn't have a big
Electronics Christmas we had a very soft
Christmas at Best Buy
what does that say that's hard data so
I'm I'm kind of I hope it's not here Pat
but I'm I'm fearful that this is a
recession coming and we're going to have
layoffs with it and then the whole thing
starts turning around when we get down
to that two percent inflation and then
you know
Adam what are your thoughts by the way
when do you see two percent inflation
being a realistic number uh Jay Powell
says when he can see it in the future
that's when he moves it so I I kind of
think he'll be able at mid-year he's
going to be looking toward the end of
the year and says you know what I can
see two percent inflation from here
you know it's funny uh you know what was
the word of the year for 2022 was like
gas lighting or I'm shocked that the
word of the year was not transitory how
many times did we hear that word travel
it's transitory inflation transitory
Janet Yellen Jay Powell everybody
transitory it's a transitory I mean
trans was like probably the word of the
year in 2022 that's a whole thing yeah
they're killing that game
um but by the way shout out to Alan
Greenspan how old do you think Alan
Greenspan is at this point he's 96 about
to be 97 this quarter in March doing his
thing uh but here's what I'll say
because we started off you've seen a few
Cycles he's you know he knows what he's
doing he's seen some transitory stuff
um here's what I'll say about because we
initiated this conversation about the
credit cards what a difference a year
makes even when the beginning of coven
when everybody was on lockdown you saw
all the savings rates were going up
credit card debt was going down people
weren't traveling people weren't
spending all of a sudden people had to
be fiscally conservative they this is
crazy right you're getting your whether
you're getting stimulus checks or
unemployment checks people actually had
to be like holy crap what is happening
right now let me get ready for this have
a budget in my life so people started
implementing that and then
after you know a year or so of lockdown
you know fighting on planes people going
nuts travel came back Airlines came back
Airline stocks came back travel Cruise
Lines everything people started
returning to normal and what is
returning to normal in America taking on
more debt baby living paycheck to
paycheck baby that's normal here in
America so I am not shocked that these
numbers that came back from credit cards
these ridiculous numbers what is the
season that people start spending the
most money Q4 this is the holiday season
between Thanksgiving you got what is it
uh Black Friday you got Cyber Monday
then you got Christmas season it's New
Year's you're spending spending spending
spending like if I'm that this is this
is this might be alarming if I'm that
person that's living paycheck to
paycheck and but but really wants to get
their significant other or family
members toys not this year baby and and
and what you have to understand is when
it comes to your money it's not a month
by month thing it's not even a it's it's
you have to look at it year over year
over year because you might have had a a
situation in 2020 where you were able to
actually to save some money and pay down
some debt but in 2021 there it was again
back to your normal that's the return to
normal that most Americans don't really
fully understand is that you're going
back to credit cards so these numbers
are horrible like for someone that made
like me that considers my themselves a
personal finance expert that's my thing
Tom you're more macroeconomics you
understand the big picture I like
helping people that make 50 Grand a year
100 Grand a year 200 Grand a year how
can you maximize the most out of your
money and when I see stats like this
it's like of course you're back to
paycheck to paycheck because did you
really need to spend three grand during
the holiday seasons and then and then
here's what's going to happen now over
the next six months prediction time tax
season is coming up okay what are you
going to do with your refund you I'm
asking you if you get a five thousand
dollar refund does that go into your
Roth IRA are you gonna max out your 401K
or is it summer see season coming around
the hot girl summer white boy summer now
we're going on vacation now we're going
to Saint Barts now we're going to
Mykonos now we're traveling these
situations that you do with three four
five six ten thousand dollars what you
decide to do with that type of money
will literally change your life but you
have to do it year over year over year
over year but most Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck thinking month to
month they don't have that long-term
Vision to to save that money that's a
good point I take you back to your own
man on the street interview with a young
lady that was down in South Florida
using uh six thousand dollars remember
that you talked to everyone remember
that yes you stand there with a go Cup
drinking in front of you and you're
asking what are you doing here are you
saving it no no we just came down here
to party man we get some free government
money habits don't change but the part
that's concerning is
where it says setting a new record of
19.14 last week that's a new record
meaning we've never done that before
okay yeah you have a good point that's
coming off the holiday season which
people are spending this is my concern
my concern is you know when you're at
the uh end of a relationship
what you guys are dating and you're kind
of like you're just waiting for the
other person to break up or it's like
you're in too deep you know it ain't
gonna go anywhere but you're comfortable
you got somebody to hang out with Friday
night Saturday whatever but you know
this shit's not going anywhere I don't
know if you've been there before I've
been there before we've all been there
so when you're in it
you're dragging and you're delaying a
time bomb that's gonna happen instead of
making a decision yeah we are delaying a
time bomb because people are gradually
running out of money all this means with
the economy not having hit rock bottom
yet it just means people still have some
savings they're sitting on and they're
waiting before they put their house on
the market because they don't have to
they're waiting before they sell that
watch because they don't they don't even
have to bother but did you see the
article I sent you about watches did you
see the one I sent you about Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter what it said if you
don't if you don't have it just pull it
up maybe I didn't send it to you no I
didn't send it to you actually go online
and type this up type out the title is
prices for Rolex just type in prices for
Rolex and I go to news
go go and click on news and should pop
up right away should the first word
should be Morgan Stanley uh okay then
type in Morgan Stanley in it as well go
back and type in Morgan Stanley and look
what it says
just go up and type in yeah Morgan
Stanley
uh there you go should come up
so interesting have it right in front of
me and it's not popping up you're doing
all the right things Rob I want to text
it to you just pull this up okay because
for the longest time when I would talk
to my Watch dealers different guys they
would say oh watch prices haven't gone
down yet is it right there watch prices
haven't gone down no it's the one I just
texted it to you okay by the way you
know how video always like to say things
like you know you've made it when yeah
when you're talking to your Watch
dealers
not watch dealer it's plural of course
dealer competition
no no you have you have to look at
what's going how pathetic is it that
you're doing writing all of it at and
it's not pulling it up that's so weird
just use the link I give you that's so
weird
no no it's not on him no it's not him
everything he did it's so weird how it
didn't pull it up with the Google
algorithm anyways there's this article
that comes out and it talks about uh the
following thing it's it's a a story
about Morgan Stanley prices for Rolex
Patek Philippe and Vladimir pajer
watches are APS will keep plunging due
to a flood of Supply but these three
real assets are still scarce and coveted
and the story is talking about how
instead of worrying about that you
should buy Farmland you should buy real
estate it's pretty much infomercial
saying what you should buy and what you
shouldn't buy and wine and it's talking
about how a lot of people right now are
investing into art and our art has
outperformed SMP by 130 something
percent the last decade our tests okay
art so no question about it there's a
there's a place in in Sweden that is
housing 100 billion dollars worth of art
it's pretty ridiculous if you see the
building what it looks like 100 billion
dollars of art being held in one place
but if you look at this read the read
the article all the way at the top again
if you can go all the way to the top
look what it says it says Morgan Stanley
prices for Rolex Patek Philippe and AP
watches will keep plunging due to a
flood of Supply right wow that in about
six months going to be replaced home
prices and real estate and Commercial
Real Estate is plunging due to flood of
Supply Bingo first people sell their
luxuries then they sell their assets wow
this comes first [ __ ] so we're delaying
a time bomb okay the first thing you do
is hey babe what are we going to do babe
sell that watch yeah babe sell that card
sell that motorcycle let's let's say
that diamond so sell sell this and then
start working out only purses baby no
Sports Chanel purses of yours sell this
sell them once all the wants and then
all of a sudden the need babe guess what
we got to sell the house this is a
delayed Time Bomb the breakup is coming
with the house it's just a matter of
time again my prediction okay the real
estate people love it when I you know
talk like this to them they get upset
and I get you know uh uh friendly emails
being sent to me I'm just telling you
this comes first then comes a real asset
this is not fake this is real it's
painful by the way watch the prices with
food okay here's the prices with food
world food prices hit record high in
2022 this is a Reuters story okay world
food prices hit record high in 2020. I'm
gonna go to you here because I know you
eat healthy food so the food and
agriculture organization FAO and the
United Nations has reported that its
food price index which tracks the
international prices of the most
globally traded food commodities has
reached the highest level on record
averaging 143.7 points in 2022 up 14.3
percent from 2021 the index has already
gained 28 in 2021 due to economic
recovery from the impact of covid-19
pandemic the increase in food prices was
largely driven by the invasion of
Ukraine by Russia in February 2022 this
is again now that that's Reuters has to
add that part to it price hike yeah and
it says it says wow food prices have uh
since partially recovered the FAO cereal
meat Dairy and vegetable oil sub-indexes
all all reach record highs in 2022 while
the sugar sub index reach a 10-year high
so you you like to buy healthy food are
you noticing anything Pat besides I buy
um I buy the online grass-fed grass
finish because you know meat if you see
a steak in in the supermarket it's like
this if you buy the natural one it's
half the size because it's you know
they're feeding it only grass it's not
grain no steroids no steroids at all uh
that that company I'm paying almost 30
percent more and I even I know the lady
that owns it I'm like what's she's like
she's like this is it is what it is so
she's so you know she's telling us yeah
I I literally can't all the prices when
she tells you that do you believe it I
100 believe it because I because I know
her and then I'm at uh Publix I'm at the
supermarket here and uh I go buy the
eggs there and the good ones and this is
a public this isn't that like Whole
Foods or whatever almost eight seven
something for eight dollars I was like
what I'm gonna just open like a chicken
coop in my apartment and just have a
laying eggs I mean my neighbors have
dogs I'm gonna get you dude it's in and
I eat like four eggs a day that's seven
dollars go it's going like that and I'm
not I eat yogurt I'm not I eat organic
yogurt but it's getting to the point
where I'm like holy [ __ ] I have to eat
half of what I'm eating and I'm getting
hungry and things I eat a lot and it's
I'm seeing it bro just for the sake of
it I have a restaurant recommendation
high-end for people that want to take
their date on can you show this
restaurant the the it's hot
it's if you're trying to impress a girl
that's where you want to take oh my God
right there and say look at the world my
God honey we made it I will say we're
loaded with eggs that's actually a great
idea I will say this that's hilarious
most people take their girl on a date
we'll go to a nice steak dinner but if
you take your girl on a date what are
you spending at a nice dinner right a
nice dinner eggs today eggs don't order
anything animal real good one 300 yeah a
couple hundred bucks easy you know what
might be a bigger turn-on for your girl
what whatever you want at Publix baby
get in there get anything thing you want
don't you stop by the way this is not an
advice Adam has given this is Adam's
Playbook this is yeah yeah we're going
to publish whatever you want
that
foreign
look at these memes 600 BC gold 1900
Monte Pablo's money today
it's insane it's insane it's all you're
gonna say Tom it's no no I was gonna ask
you what are you doing about it Vinnie I
mean like how are you solving the
economy Vinnie as a comedian what is
your role here
origination and CCI comes down there's a
lot of people like you out there trying
to eat eat healthy and try to figure it
out what do you suggest in the middle of
this
yeah well I'm I'm cutting back I'm
literally cutting the food in half the
which is I'm being dead serious are you
joking I'm being dead seriously you're
not cutting I'm like eating I'm saying
I'm eating less of the good [ __ ] and now
I'm being forced to buy the unorganic
[ __ ] but I'm trying I'm literally trying
to find the one that's the least
unhealthy I'm still not doing the sugar
[ __ ] I'm not doing all that but bro it's
getting to the point where it's now like
because mind you I have obligations in
my life that I take care of some people
and I do some things but it's like I'm
getting to the point where I'm even
telling people like send money to us as
well I can't do it anymore I can't like
I you want to borrow money I it's over
because the egg situation is getting
ridiculous so Blake why don't we invest
in a freaking Pat the other building
that you what do you think those 600
chickens in a bad car that's exactly
right do you think they just found made
it here 17 parking spaces I replace it
let me tell you every morning you hear
them the goose that laid the golden egg
was a fairy tale our 600 chickens is
real baby yeah but if you do actually
want to be solution oriented actually
unfortunately the thing that you
genuinely have to cut out of your life
is your FNB budget as far as going out
to restaurants night clubs that kind of
stuff take out doordash ubereats that's
the stuff that's weighing you down yes
maybe you usually spend a hundred bucks
at the grocery store now it's a buck 20.
I get it that 20 dollars is not going to
change your life so yes eggs are going
to be a little bit more expensive yes
you're going to spend a little bit more
at your local supermarket yeah but
that's still a way better option than
the alternative which is eating out at
restaurants yeah and so unfortunately a
lot of restaurants if this economy does
continue in this direction where we're
seeing this recession who's really going
to take the hurt are these small
businesses these restaurants these
employees at these restaurants
18 months trying to get back on their
feet after the government told them and
this is a perfect example and you say it
trickles down so now that the money's
like this and the food dating and
everything is getting ridiculous because
hey I'm not taking them out I'm not I
can't I'm sorry we'll just go home and
chill he's gonna go home and chill ready
you know like my mom could cook I could
oh I'm not a chef like my brother my mom
but I know how to cook bro it's it's
ridiculous I have an idea for you matter
of fact if 10 interim Bumble is
listening to this okay do you know how
you go on Yelp yeah
Yelp app and you get to choose
restaurants based on one dollar sign two
dollars three or four yeah Tinder and
Bumble has to put with a girl put listen
I only I'm cheap I'm good I'm good with
I'm good with Denny's I'm good with
Friday yeah
it'll be eggs how many eggs
I don't know by the way that would be
the funniest thing if they did for one
day on April I'm a cheap date and for
girls like I got no standards one drink
gets me drunk I'm going home with you
one glass of wine you're my kind of girl
you know hold on you're you're a fine
egg kind of girl yeah like you know
Rotten Tomatoes by the way by the way I
have a bone to pick with you what I have
a straight up bone to pick with this is
this is part of the economy yeah you my
friend you were supposed to bring us
some liver Pat and I hate it hold on bro
the guy is barely eating I'm I'm about
to eat Tom's liver live I know this is
my bone at least liver the liver King
was Syria no shirt on nipples hard
smelled horrible boom you're like I got
the liver but what about nipples now the
economy just you know this little little
food for thought the liver is not that
expensive even though the organic one
and then okay let's next home team
podcast I'm gonna break but this is why
I'm I have a bone to pick up yeah
I'm done with my workout and let me tell
you what I can smell from a mile away
I've been gifted with a massive milk I
have this gift you're like the Middle
Eastern nose I smell I I smell what's
cooking out there I smell right across
the street they just put the chicken on
the um
I'm in the gym working out and I start
smelling liver oh my God I'm telling you
and I come in Melva has put she does
this once a month but she surprises me
liver is sitting right there and I Like
It Raw cooked a little bit like 30
seconds 20 seconds and I eat this liver
I haven't had a meal for years okay I
mean there's nothing I don't know what
else to do this is not a liver and
onions this is just Raw Liver we know
there's no onions involved no no no
there's voice
you know I know that your nose is good
like he's met me we've hung up maybe
twice I walked into the building and my
cologne is very like this you know it's
me pad goes Vinny's here
I was all I was like but you have you
have a very good scent you're very I
don't play around with no no you're good
and I can't tell you guys but if you
want to message me on Instagram so by
the way so girl has to choose would I
rather have a guy that smells good but
the food we're gonna eat is going to be
cheaper or would I have a guy that has
to put so much cologne because he smells
so horrible but he cooks well I'm
choosing number one number one are you
gonna win or ten times anyway
okay on competes okay we need something
knocked right so FTC proposal to ban
non-compete clauses here we go I love it
when this starts this way so FTC says
proposal to ban non-compete clauses
could boost
pay by 300 billion dollars a year now
let's see who's saying this could boost
300 billion dollars per year okay so
your FTC has proposed a rule that would
ban the non-com class in the United
States the rule would prevent uh
employers from imposing Clauses and
contracts that prohibit employees from
joining a competitor after leaving the
company typically for a set of period of
time proponents of the rule argue that
non-competed agreements contribute to
wage stagnation by limiting the ability
of workers to switch jobs to secure
higher pay opponents argue that
non-complete Clauses facilitate
retention and encourage companies to
invest in training and promote employees
especially in a tight labor market at
the FTC estimates that this could boost
wages by nearly 300 billion dollars
annually and expand career opportunities
for approximately 30 million Americans
by the way they have no clue if that
does or not the last part is purely
propaganda saying they estimate that the
rule could boost could boost 300 billion
dollars annually and expand career
opportunities for approximately 30
million Americans Tom we know a lot
about noun competes you've been in the
business space for a long time you know
what this means you know who which state
is the worst non-compete state which is
the state of California right what are
your thoughts on this non-compete
proposal that they're given well first
of all I want to when a government
agency uses the phrase 30 million
Americans it's it's so funny you should
just Google that and go back because
remember Obama said we have to do this
for health care for the 30 million
Americans who need coverage remember
that it's always 30 million Americans
needed what are these 30 million people
they're talking about I'd like to know
where they are maybe they're talking
about California because it's exactly 30
million exactly it's all those you know
it's all those fake statistics like when
you you hear that you know every 16
seconds a woman somewhere in the world
is having a baby and I'm like well then
that's the girl you gotta stop
it's hilarious you just got to find her
yeah but whenever I see this stuff think
about it but let's talk about
non-competes this is just the headline
and this is being put out by the
government because let me tell you how
non-competes really work I work for you
whoever's listening here and you don't
want me you want me to have a
non-compete so you say that if I leave
you know that for two years I can't
recruit anybody well that's disruption I
can't do that and for two years I can't
tortiously interfere with any of your
contracts like steal your customers okay
well that's already on the books but
this if you want to keep somebody in
non-compete you have to pay them a
little bit we've seen this we see it in
financial services sector you know I'm
going to give you half your salary for
one year and one year and then when that
expires you can go do something else
that's what a non-compete is you know
what they call it in the UK it's called
gardening leave well he's on gardening
leave and it's built in to your contract
this is if you're going to leave they
will pay you one year of your salary to
be on gardening leave now what that
means is for one year your brain is not
being paid by a competitor
so it makes a gap between the time you
leave to the time that your brain is
working for somebody else that's how
non-competes work somebody in government
seems to think that the non-competes
prevent somebody from getting a higher
paying job no it doesn't
I've had people tell me you've had
people tell you what are you doing I'm
just waiting out a year and I'm taking
this other job and I'm doing this I got
a really good job it's a good
opportunity and I'm waiting a year and
I'm taking it this is this is a nothing
Burger you know non-competes are built
to protect the company but you can't
handcuff somebody from making a living
in the United States
with a non-compete there has to be
consideration and Pat you and I have
dealt with a lot of lawyers to say well
what consideration are you willing to
pay him for six months so that he sits
it out he or she before they take the
next job you know for me I'll give it to
you from a couple different perspectives
first of all I don't think non-competes
have any weight today anyways like you
know how sign in NDA okay when's the
last time an India carried anyway do you
know how many ndas I've had signed and
people have you know flipped on the NDA
ncas have some uh uh weight they still
carry some weight in certain States
not competeers no non-compete yeah
agreement so a non-compete carries some
weight but not an NDA here's a challenge
so the thing the market has to realize
is the following here's what the market
has to realize
you know how sometimes you go and you
negotiate for something and then when
you get it and you get in the car and
you're like oh [ __ ] I got what I wanted
why did I get what I wanted
what are the consequences of what I got
could man
he just sat there and he said yes to it
holy moly what is he gonna do about this
okay cool let's process this together
hey uh Mr employer uh if you don't give
me a raise I'm gonna go to this other
company and they'll allow me to work
from home and they're paying me forty
thousand dollars more with a twenty
thousand dollar signing bonus but I'm
telling you if you give me a 20 000
signing bonus forty thousand dollar
raise and allow me to work from home I
won't go anywhere I'll still loyal to
you um
many employers experienced that in 2021
what happened today you know what's the
first thing Bob Iger said yesterday go
to Bob Iger and put four day work week
type in Bob Iger four day work week okay
Bob I agree yesterday right there just
the top article right to click on that
Bob Iger uh uh uh said uh yeah Bob Baker
just yesterday said zoom in a little bit
Bob agarista they said everybody's got
to return to work four days a week from
the start of March this is Disney woke
all of that stuff it doesn't work
working from home period no you're not
more productive with a Frigidaire and
the TV during the video game there stop
trying to convince people and all these
huffle writers and all these journalists
who all they do is write and you know do
what they do none of them actually know
what when they talk about how it's
beneficial to work from home no it's not
I can tell you right now it's not
beneficial for me to work from home and
I'm a pretty disciplined guy yesterday
I'm trying to shoot a video from my
office I'm not even kidding with you I
turn off the light so everybody knows
and I have a big house so I can hide
from everybody and I still can't hide
first jumbo comes by the window
you know how long Jimbo will bark until
I open the door 10 minutes so people on
the zoom are hearing Jimbo bark so then
I go tell Jimbo be quiet it works for
five minutes five minutes later
then Tico comes Hey Dad I have a corn
video I want to show you so I have to
watch his corn video with 27 minutes
with this kid that made a porn video on
two songs then I tell Tico that's funny
then he leaves Senna comes hey can I get
in your lap hi Vinnie hi Vinnie when are
we gonna make another video down like
Santa can you please leave then Jen
comes back hey babe did you call me babe
I'm trying to shoot a video what would
you like to eat then she lives and my
dad comes back
okay so then it comes back hey Kim
honestly you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna I'm gonna call tikon right now you
know what time what time was our pump
what time was our prep for deposit six
thirds what time was our prep course
dude you really lies I'm doing this
video I'm calling tikram right now so
tikra knows okay
literally
you're on the podcast last night you and
I Karina comes and says let's schedule a
one hour to do the video right which I
knew that was not gonna work out so when
you and I did that we did the podcast
prep you and I got on at 6 30. yeah what
time did you and I finish with
everything last night my time not your
time your time it was 10 30 10 45. this
is supposed to be one hour because I'm
sitting there everyone's interrupting
by the way if you don't know tikron he's
one of the most incredible special
greatest men in the world loved by
everybody we love you shout out here in
the game we love you Tico hey give your
president wife a uh high five oh thank
you that's a high value
no here's what I'm trying to tell you
don't tell me you are more focused at
your house yeah and by the way to the
fools who bought it
to the fools who were Executives who
bought this [ __ ] that was sold to
them it's like a six-year-old kid
selling mommy and daddy who are 40 years
old why it's okay for the six-year-old
boy to be in a room with a six-year-old
girl and close the door nothing's gonna
happen exactly what the hell did we do
when we were that age yeah so so now for
these people to say well not compete
it's because it's going to increase the
economy by 300 billion dollars you know
what the employer says all right cool I
already know visually what meetings are
coming up you know what the meeting is
I'm gonna give you the visual tell me if
you believe this or not okay here we go
with the visual
hey Patrick you know I love working with
you I love what you stand for by the way
I'm giving this script for other people
yeah they want to use it again
take notes everybody it's been great
employees but I'm gonna tell you you
know I think I've earned the right to
get a 50 raise and if you don't give it
to me I'm going directly to the
competitor because they've offered me
three jobs to go to the direct
competitor and and they feel the Intel
that I've learned from being here all
the strategies of how we come up with
clips and how we cut them and how we do
this and how we get sponsorship all our
contacts I'm going to take it over to
the competitor but okay if you pay me
this I will never betray you never
because I'm a loyal type of a guy
that's why you laughing that script Rob
was going to use the script not wrote
that because they lay it all out and
then they go by the way I'm loyal
only twice as much
think about but you guys are laughing no
I'm telling you I'm on the other side I
sit in front of some of these people and
they use these scripts and I'm like
did you just tell me and you made a
threat and then you told me you're um
you believe in loyalty yeah so so here's
the point guys go ahead and do it go for
it you know what all this means if for
those who want the CEO and the executive
to fully work on them and lock onto them
and hey I'm gonna be the next person
that CEO and that guy is sitting there
saying I'm looking for guys I had an
interview the other day
four four
I spoke to a very powerful person in
America the other day Okay and we're
having this conversation
and a conversation came about this one
person another very very powerful person
in the world
and he says let me tell you about this
one person everybody knows who you know
you know who this person I'm just not
saying the name and don't say anything I
don't know Adam so say it yeah so I'm
talking to this person and the
conversation goes about well listen
Patrick obviously we've been following
your work for years
he says how important is loyalty to you
I said very he says tell me the names of
people that you trust trust trust
that you know you can talk openly and I
gave nine names business me and Adam and
Pat oh for sure but nine names I gave
right and I give these nine names and
first name status I'm giving these nine
names and he says okay so you understand
the bigger you get how much harder it is
to trust people because of how many
people backstab you yes
that guy's been backstabbed so many
times
that the bigger you get it's harder to
trust more people
and I totally agree with them now here's
the benefit if a guy like that or me or
somebody that's going to be growing
businesses for many many years
takes a liking to you and starts working
with you there's a very high likely
chance you're going to win that that's
the that's the uh what what factor
that's the X Factor when when there is
somebody behind closers like you know
for me
I'm not getting spiritual on you but I'm
convinced a lot of the things that
happen to me I'm convinced I've read a
book called David and Goliath that says
people who are close who had a close
call of dying they feel they have a
certain you know not connection like you
have certain favor like you think you're
supposed to do you're destined right
it's a very interesting way he explains
it but I think God's on my side and I
think God's on our side and I think what
we're doing is a necessary message that
we have and I think miracles happen
right there's a very unique confidence
that show when you walk around known
somebody like that's got your back you
just walk different you talk different
you process different you do things in a
different way when you know someone has
it kids have that when they know who
their dad is you know players do that
when they have a coach a coach doesn't
want the owners be there is a certain
feeling now you want to take this
approach all you're doing is for the
employees that are going to think about
using this against the employer good
luck to you good luck to what happens
and go on the marketplace and see if
that strategy is going to work out by
the way again all this does the
stupidity of things like this it creates
a division between the employer and the
employee as if we don't already have
enough
division let's add some more division
between employer and employees and act
like we're on the employee side keep
doing that and see what happens and you
can only do this once by the way yeah
yeah once you know if you pull this
trick off and you get a little bit of
money they know you're not loyal you're
probably not going to get a next
promotion at the place you just extorted
the arrays from and if you left anyway
you know if you really did that with a
new employer if someone came to me if I
was a week let's say I was a weak-minded
kind of a low ethics uh competitor and
I'm welcoming A salesperson to bring in
all these you know contacts that came
from the other company or something or
or information they really shouldn't
have brought in my door do I trust him
no because I can set my watch means
someday he's going to do that to me for
his next job so it doesn't work this way
you're absolutely right Pat it doesn't
work you you get marked you pull it off
once you're still a marked person
because you respect honesty like you
you'd rather have somebody walk in not
with all this gimmick [ __ ] and just
be like Pat like even and even if they
got emotion like Pat
I need this raise
eggs
for a dozen and I have a date coming
over
she wants an eye that would actually
work that would work
you know I want to cook for you you come
in the bathroom
I'll serve you what would you like take
a bottle I'll bring you dozens of eggs
just take it home but I love you I was
gonna do this whole gimmick [ __ ]
about staying home [ __ ] by the way
here's a skid do a skin saying hey girl
I'm gonna take you to a place tonight
yeah we're gonna go to a nice you should
make a video a little okay give them a
comedy and you take her and you show
eggs
oh dude she says oh my God this guy's
loaded and she calls a girlfriend you
will not believe we're having dinner I
look at the back by the kitchen what he
had ten dozen eggs
or get organic you should make holy [ __ ]
make marriage that's hilarious
hey go back to uh go back to the Iger
thing that's so funny because what's
it's all come home to ruse Tim Armstrong
who was CEO of all Verizon media if I
had one piece above by the way think
about this this is 18 months later Pat
remember you'll work from home help the
workers they're going to give you the
same thing they're going to be doing all
this stuff right Tim Armstrong if I have
one piece of advice for you young people
in your 30s go back to work get in the
office you can't build meaningful
constructive relationships with your
counterparts through Zoom as a result
you're going to miss out on personal
development and promotion opportunities
they come to the office when they want
to raise they come to the office when
they want a promotion then I ask them
how have you engaged with your
co-workers how have you developed no
answer now let's go back down here third
paragraph for Iger because it's all
coming back
Bob Iger as you've heard me say many
times creativity is the heart and soul
of who we are and what we do at Disney
and then a creative business like ours
nothing can replace the ability to
connect observe and create with peers
that comes from physically being
together nor the opportunity to grow
professionally by learning from leaders
and mentors 18 months later Pat remember
there was a war on business and a war I
a let him work from home I won't hurt
your productivity it's complete BS it's
all coming back but by the way you know
you know what's crazy
is I I'm a extremely skeptical paranoid
I'm you know when I mean like in
business that's kind of like you know
military not necessarily but you know I
mean very but you're joking that's Tom
sarcasm but you know when you when you
have the life I've lived and you're kind
of in the situations I've been you kind
of sitting there saying what's going on
over here in the middle of covid you're
listening to everybody and there's one
side on your you know shoulder you got
the one guy on the other guy one guy's
like you got to take the shot you're an
idiot if you don't another guy's saying
dude we don't know what we're doing
right in the middle of covet when they
said well you gotta let everybody work
from home what are you that's unfair why
are you being such an old school you
sound like an 80 year old CEO from the
60s let people work from home these
Millennials you need to learn from them
liberate them yeah and the other side is
like no no no no don't buy into it yes
you're being too tough on your kids your
kids are in two two two two tough on
these guys and the other side no [ __ ]
look at the life they got an easy life
hey you're being unfair with the
standards you're creating loosen up a
little bit now that's what great leaders
do this too the hardest part is when
you're in the thick of things when
everybody's telling you to go work from
home and I'm on board calls and on these
board calls well Patrick maybe maybe
you're not being fair maybe you ought to
consider what these younger people are
asking for that hey maybe you're not
being responsible enough you should send
somebody to everybody's office and offer
free vaccine to everybody that's a board
call I had Tom you were on that call
maybe you should send a hey maybe you
these in these moments
when you're you're sitting there and
you're making a decision and you walk
away you could be wrong it's in those
moments that the trust in you goes
higher where you have to trust yourself
this doesn't mean you're going to be 100
right all the time yeah but some of this
is common sense of course and it's so
hard to lean on Common Sense while 90 of
people who have fancy degrees who are
more educated than you are selling you a
story that when you're by yourself
you're saying maybe that guy's smarter
than me maybe they're right maybe that
it's in those moments that you realize
how strong can you do me a favor what
was the tone of the voice of the board
call how that wasn't me speaking no no
no no hold on because this person I was
shaking my head
first of all if I do the voice I'm not
gonna do the voice because people know
well guess what are they from California
but the point is and by the way the
people who said that to me yeah I love
those of course FYI without those guys
we don't create the valuation and the
business that we've been I'm telling you
here right I believe it but in those
moments
how do you make your decision what is
this something from inside you from what
makes you go you know what I'm gonna do
my own thing I get what thanks for the
advice but here's the thing you know the
whole thing about like you know some
some people are sending me messages
about Jordan Peterson what do you think
what's going on with Jordan Peterson
we'll talk about his story right now as
well what do you think about what's
going on with Tate what do you think
what's going on with this what do you
think what's going on with that here's
here's what I do know any one of us who
think we're right 100 of time you're a
fool of course any one of us who think
we know it all all the time about all
things you're a fool okay there's
nothing attractive about that human
being okay and by the way we all are
tempted to feel that way and the cause
of that is when people around you tell
you how amazing you are is because you
don't sit with opposition okay the
problem when you don't sit with
opposition and you only sit with people
that think you're so amazing you're
you're like you know how much hate I got
for having Reza salana really oh I can
imagine oh my god do you know how many
people tweeted at me called I had a call
last night saying why would you have
results something like dude what's one
of my favorite podcasts yeah why would
you have you know uh Kyle kulinski I
freaking had a blast with the guy
because you're finding leaks right so
you're asking a question to me dude
there's been many times I've made a
decision and I've been wrong and I had
to learn okay but in certain decisions
that has to do with values and
principles I'm not compromising you stay
right on yourself you keep the course
they know because my loyalty is the to
the people that that bought into the
vision when we sold the company like
what we're gonna do one day when I sold
them 13 and a half years ago my
loyalties to those people there is no
what we're doing today without those
guys at the beginning zero my goal was
to make sure all of those guys became
financially free Palio today just bought
a three million dollar house in Austin
got a beautiful wife beautiful Junior
beautiful kid beautiful family very
happy in Austin Gaitan just bought a two
and a half something million dollar
house in huge Houston drives a nice car
kids go to Great private schools he's an
incredible father mom's an incredible
mother to have three boys seeing what
happened with Rodolfo and CeCe Vargas
incredible life they're living in a
beautiful home you know few million
dollars in a bank they've saved they've
done this guy was a guy that worked a
lost prevention at Sears wow and he went
back to El Salvador to get married
seeing what's happened with Matt sappal
who just bought a three million dollar
home in Dallas Texas beautiful
basketball tennis court stairs of like
the Tony Montana type of stairs when you
come walking and they're living an
incredible life they're both leaders
Iowa to them because without them we
don't have what we have but exactly I'm
the leader yeah and my my my depression
isn't for me to be right 100 of the time
the pressure is I may be wrong but I'm
okay with that but I don't compromise
values and principles and I I don't
think neither should the rest of us no
matter how great the argument may make
you should always leave and out to say
guys we could be wrong the whole problem
with covet was what all they said is
they're 100 right and others are 100
that's just it's just not cool to do
that okay so I'm not sitting here trying
to tell you how amazing we did all this
other stuff believe me I can tell you 50
different mistakes I made yeah but I'm
okay with that but I'm not compromising
values and principles I respect those
are the things that we have to work on
again
if you do in the past when you do
because we are tempted we're all Sinners
we all make mistakes you're typically
going to get yourself in trouble it's
just not necessary life is as you age
and you make money and you've had
incredible experiences man there's so
much there's not a lot of more valuable
things than great relationships of
people that strengthen you that
challenge you
and you enjoy hanging out with them you
can put your feet up and just relax and
not give a [ __ ] and just talk about life
and watch and hey what are your favorite
singers what's your favorite sports
let's debate this let's play dominoes
let's play spades I just played Spades
the other day with Ella suazo with Jamie
Musgrove with
otay rubenote
tikram beckyan and Maurice Hansberry
one's from uh New Orleans Ellis very
handsome guy one Maurice tansberry love
that guy he's from Chicago uh I think
he's from a different place but ended up
in Chicago and then Jamie musco from
Memphis say belote from Memphis and then
secrets from Armenia right The Armenian
guy two Armenian guys
whooped on him yes proudly yeah and they
came to say y'all don't know how to play
Spades really okay you must not have a
clue who I spend most of my life with
yeah we sat down we played Spades the
only person I got a good credit to it's
very uncomfortable to do this Jamie
mosgrove is legit he's good she's good
but by the way cut this part I don't
want I want you to cut the screen I
don't want her to look at that kind of a
recognition
Jamie's legit when it comes down to
space it's okay to play against Ellis
and he's good it's okay to place against
Hansberry or rotate they're good if
Jaime says let's play space for money
run don't take your money run put away
your credit card take away your app with
apple she's good but again
we started playing cards at 10 o'clock
that night Tom and I left at 3 30 at
night in the morning okay for five and a
half hours all we did is play cards talk
[ __ ] have a cigar outside Fort
Lauderdale underwater with a house with
Madison Isabella chilling I mean you
couldn't pick that that that right there
is that worth a hundred thousand dollars
is that worth a half a million dollars
to me that's probably absolutely life is
about those moments those relationships
you ought to value that and uh if you
can do that and make money and make
history and make a difference and do
something that's ever been done before
now you're part of the lucky lucky lucky
very very very few yep that's cool to be
a part of that anyways I don't know how
the hell we got into space but I just
really wanted to call out Ellis
I'm showing my flaws I cannot believe it
that was a call out it was work from
home you make mistakes you learn from
mistakes you need well we beat you
but you lost but what is never a mistake
is investing in your people playing
cards until 3am those are those are good
memories okay let's go to let's go to
the next door do we want to do
Rolls-Royce let's just get that knocked
out of the way by the way just for some
of you guys that buy rolls royces for a
living uh Rolls-Royce went and had their
biggest year ever Rolls-Royce Harold's
momentous year as Car Sales exceed 6 000
for the first time
um uh for the first time in 118 year
history the company saw particularly
strong you're on your growth in the
Middle East Asia Pacific and U.S and
Europe in 2022 with a single digit drop
in sales in Greater China interesting so
China bought fewer Rolls Royce everybody
else bought more which was successfully
counterbalanced by increased sales in
other markets some 6021 cars were
delivered to customers last year an
increase of eight percent from 2021 with
demand for all models remaining
exceptionally strong in advance orders
secured
far into 2023 the value of uh bespoke
bespoke commissions also reached record
level highs with clients willing to pay
around a half a million dollar half a
million euros for a unique Rolls-Royce
Adam what are their chances of you one
day on a Rolls-Royce well thank you for
teeing that up you know I was talking to
my Rolls-Royce dealers today
I've got a couple I'm vetting them yeah
just to make sure I'm getting the best
deal on the rules
well I will say that you know my voice
they're probably mostly Middle Eastern
100 my Rolls-Royce dealers know your
Rolex dealers they're in communication
uh I don't know what percentage of the
world is even looking into buying a
Rolls-Royce 6021 of them yeah okay so
out of eight billion out of eight
billion yeah this is a very small Market
but I guess where I'm going with this is
we just read the article about if
whether it's a Rolex or an Audemars
piquette or what's uh yeah yeah or uh
you know you know it's expensive when
you start talking like this yeah
but like the first things to go are your
wants right like you talked about
whether it's watches anything with the
motor cars uh you know boats motorcycles
all that so I guess I'm my question is
I'm grappling with if all these wants
are going down luxury goods why are
roses Royce going up because my guess is
the rich have gotten richer the support
have gotten poorer like you could be a
paycheck to paycheck guy you can make a
hundred grand a year and you're like you
know what I kind of want that freaking
uh that Rolex and you'll spend some
money on a watch you ain't doing that
with the Rolls Royce Rolls Royce is for
the elite of the elite of the elite it
comes with the drive yes exactly what I
mean so right now I'm just negotiating
with my two or three uh Rolls-Royce
dealers and jump seeing what I can come
up with right now but now's a good time
to uh to find these luxury assets on a
good agree with them the fact that the
to the rich you know by the way I just
did a number right now if a person
bottle Rolls-Royce yesterday 6021 of
them sold we got eight million people
you ever heard that song you're one in a
million you're one in a million you're
officially one in
1.328682 million people about the
lottery how much is a Rolls Royce how
many hundred million yeah half a million
like I'm patches
that's the world the Phantom is going to
be 650. Dawn is going to be 400 Grand a
ghost is going to be 350 drop head you
already dropped you you're looking at
anywhere between 350 to 700 000. how
much is a Maybach maybe is about three
hundred thousand dollars well oh oh by
the way congratulations on the new car I
just saw sitting out there yeah I love
that tell me about that but so you got
rid of one car to get this one no I
didn't get rid of it the other one is in
the garage he's just sleeping it's
chilling I just trying to get rid of it
but this one the Porsche Turbo S it's
sick Cabriolet oh my God ridiculous I am
in love so you're not getting Anatomy
kidding with you I'm in love that's sick
now yeah I mean it's zero to sixty two
point two seconds comfortable
comfortable it's big inside you have to
sit in it I can't yeah
I'm gonna take you you're going to see
how it goes you have a deal you're gonna
sit there you're gonna say holy [ __ ]
you'll see when it flies it's an amazing
it's so bad when you drive a car that's
worth okay that's a really that's a
house 460 000 literally like somebody's
driving that for you or you're not
people I don't see that many people that
that if that's your car because bro any
dink any anything that's like I'll call
like you have to pay like how much 10
000 so anything on any damage under this
your rims your everything it's
ridiculous first of all when I when I
had the dawn I had a flat tire Tom you
can correct me if I'm exactly
exaggerating okay over a two-year period
I drove it every day yeah how many flat
tires did I have honestly in two years
in two years but two of them are two of
them per month
also you weren't you you you you you
called Jen right now no I remember that
but I remember the first one where
you call the number you suddenly hear
helicopters overhead guys are dropping
down on ropes and they're suddenly
changing the changing your tires and
apologizing I had I probably had 12 flat
tires
in two years that's why but let me tell
you what happened here's what would
happen they come they pick it up they go
change the tires no one [ __ ] they
bring it back to you that's uh the
service it's ridiculous well I would
hope you get that some type of services
spending a half a million dollars to get
that service with Mercedes oh no you
don't get that service with Mercedes and
you can even a couple hundred thousand
no no but that's still yeah but you get
the service with them the level of
details like the the leather they use
inside is with cows who have never had
mosquito bites what are you joking no no
I'm telling you oh my no no I'm telling
you like the the stuff the story when
you see the story behind what they do
the floor mats are real walls yeah by
the way the hand like the the what do
you call a steering wheel the leather on
the steering wheel it's like only four
people in the world that sold all of
them on and the way they do it it's like
the more and more you hear those stor
everything is like handle the the clock
in the middle the watch in the middle
the the level of Ingenuity and detailed
so just don't go to a Rolls-Royce
dealership because when they start
talking to you like this you literally
oh you're like you are gonna buy your
Rolls Royce I don't you love Rolls-Royce
you will max out your credit cards and
get a Rolls Royce I don't care if eggs
are expensive Rolls-Royce is cheap
that's what they're gonna do to you and
you're like oh [ __ ] Ma I gotta roll I
should buy rolls I don't know but I got
it it's on that's credit it's a Mom's
credit on the on the inner of the Rolls
Royce on the dashboard you know they
have the the clock it's very fancy clock
it's actually built from human skin that
has never had a mosquito wow
but by the way here's a little tip to
save that money if you're gonna if
you're interested in a Rolls Royce
here's what you do you go to the car
dealership you go you go right up to the
dealer and you say show me where the
Chrysler 300s are yeah you go buy that
same car you go steal the Rolls-Royce uh
Insignia of Pat's car yeah you glue that
on yeah you take your girl not to a hot
date restaurant you take her to Publix
now we're saving that freaking look at
that do that we're driving Chrysler 300s
we're not driving roses we're not
getting out at the fancy restaurants
we're saving money on eggs this is your
game plan for 2023 ladies and gentlemen
I think this is good I'll tell you why I
think it's good because there's a lot of
people that are taking pride in their
work who will never own a Rolls-Royce
that are building them and have jobs at
that company yeah and get back to the
biz dog no no I mean you people say oh
the rich are getting richer yeah but
they're buying things that are built by
other people who have a really good job
doing that so I kind of look at it as as
net benefit because there's there others
there are four or five people that make
whatever they make a year that are
sewing leather and are doing leather
selection and everything what do you do
I do leather selection for Rolls Royce
so it's perfect yeah by the way once
every podcast I try to give the bizdoc
shout out for when he hits nail on the
headphone here we go if you hate rich
people listen to what Tom just said for
all those 6 000 people that are buying
Rolls-Royce is out there how many jobs
has this created whether you're doing
the leather and the wheels and the
steering wheel all this stuff or you're
selling one in Miami jobs are being
created because rich people want lunch
guys this is totally random but that's
how my brain works do you think those
Rolls-Royce cows know that they're like
first of all zero mosquitoes
impact number two ready for this because
all the other ones are gonna die and go
to whatever and they're like guys
when I die I'm gonna be seats and a
steering wheels boots on some idiot
enjoy your McDonald's okay Vinnie I tell
you one of the greatest salesmen I
appreciate it so much one time myself
Jennifer uh Steve and taline we go to a
restaurant in San Francisco called
Alexander Alexander Steakhouse yeah can
you type in Alexander Steakhouse and
where is it where is that it's in San
Francisco I've heard of it I've heard of
that yeah so we go to this restaurant
and a waiter says would you like to hear
about our special
beef and steak that we have of course I
said yeah I'd love to Mr Jones we'll
explain it to you another guy has to
come so guy with a British accent and
whatever his main name maybe something
else but he shows up fake accent and by
the way just looking like money yeah and
he starts explaining the steak that they
have from Australia is I said how much
is this it says 12 ounce 400 is it 1200
I said it's okay sell it to me okay so
me and Steve were like dude we have to
try this sell me this pen what's your
name here's what's so special about this
beef number one
has been listening to classical music
I'm telling you it's been this Mozart
only for this music it's entire life
Beethoven Mozart only oh it has the best
kind of beer every day oh my God yep it
gets massages every day Zero mosquito
bites you are possibly eating the best
meat beef you'll ever eat in your entire
life it melts in your mouth like ice
cream so I said either this guy's full
of [ __ ] I want it yeah yeah so we order
it okay no joke it shows up I'm getting
hungry just thinking oh my God just mess
myself up look at look at it so I I cut
the meat why'd you do that that was like
cuties so I cut the meat Vinnie you know
what happens the meat the meat Falls and
you know how it just like jello no it's
still jiggling for like five seconds
it's so good I put it in my mouth when I
eat the steak take a bite out of it
I had a moment with God it was a
spiritual moment
it was so good it was insane that's how
good it was Stevie said he has a similar
reaction yeah so you know part of this
is the story yeah where it's kind of
like the audience is sitting there
saying I don't know if you're full of
[ __ ] or not but I want it yeah and part
of it is if it delivers man kudos to you
this thing delivered so let me ask you a
question just just really really fast
cop being a cow yeah would you rather be
the cow that's pampered and massage and
beer but you're gonna die or would you
rather be the guy that just is in that
room just like it's coming because the
other guys the one Kyle's like they're
never gonna do anything crazy to me I'm
gonna live forever but he knows he
doesn't think he's gonna die the other
ones are just like they just go up to
him and just and you can feel it like
you said they're not listening to music
listen to the people Hicks and people
talk in the back and yelling and stuff
like that so just nice and calm life and
makes you relaxed and the meat tastes
well that cowboy accent in Australia
sounds fantastic sounds good huh brother
little advice for you buddy yeah
doing your dating and everything that
you're doing
why buy the cow if you get the milk for
free what I'm saying brother why would
you well I have no idea go ahead and
milk that thing all right let's go to
the next store
steak and eggs good the chicken's
involved but the cows committed
exactly that's hilarious all right so
let's go to the next one do we want to
do business do we want to do a little
pilot let's go to Kevin McCarthy let's
go to Kevin McCarthy all night when it
was announced Adam was texting me was so
fired up so Kevin McCarthy I like to
speak of the house ending days of
Republican chaos and division of
Washington Insider story Kevin McCarthy
was selected as the speaker of the house
after a lengthy and chaotic selection
process that took place over several
days McCarthy secured the position after
15 ballots in the early hours of the
fifth day of voting
he was able to win over more than a
dozen votes on Friday giving him the
necessary support to become speaker
McCarthy's Victory came after a series
of events on the house floor including
the confrontation between two
representative and a last-minute effort
by McCarthy to secure support the
speaker of the house is second in line
of presidential succession Adam what are
your thoughts when you saw this did you
see how many times it took for him to
get elected because breaking news he got
he he is now efficient he's a speaker of
the house you do realize the Speaker of
the House the third in line for the
president this ain't no little small
task he just took Nancy Pelosi's job by
the way if you're I know we have a
massive audience all four of you that
are huge fans of uh Nancy Pelosi she is
no longer the Speaker of the House the
the House minority leader is now Hakeem
Jeffries out of uh New York and New York
but I think this was a big deal this was
something that if you like soap operas
you know get a load of this you saw what
happened with Matt Gates and he tried to
yeah drama and then the other guy showed
up he tell you you know just you know
how they said like you don't don't watch
the sausage get made you know Pat you
say something all the time about like uh
the relationship we have with our
parents I'm gonna try to use a metaphor
with politicians you say when you're
young you idolize your parents right and
then
um when as you get older a teenager you
kind of villainize your parents right
but then as as you become an adult you
tend to humanize your parent I kind of
look at that with politics especially
with Trump and everything that happened
with him is you're either like idolizing
Trump right or anyone in in the Trump
Camp uh or you're villainizing Trump and
what I did genuinely with Kevin McCarthy
was I wasn't trying to idolize him I'm
not a fan I'm not trying to villainize
him he's an American I'm not
anti-establishment I'm not anti Kevin
McCarthy I just genuinely tried to
humanize Kevin McCarthy and I actually
listened to his speech did you listen to
his speech by the way when he became
speaker of the house after two days of
no no no no no no no no no no no it was
still his speech was fantastic it was
moving it was powerful it was real you
know he's got people on the left that
obviously don't like him he's got people
on the far right that probably like like
him even less you know the freedom
caucus everything you know the Matt
Gates is of the world the Lauren bobritz
of the world Marjorie Taylor green but I
actually just tried to humanize Kevin
McCarthy and you know the knock on him
is he's just like establishment swamp
creature he raised 300 million dollars
but I actually listened to his speech
and when I tell you I was like genuinely
moved when he started talking about
Lincoln and I'm sure there's an element
of like
you know diplomacy and being a
politician and just kind of just but I
actually just tried to humanize him for
a second and what he said was sometimes
when he's all alone
in this chamber
he'll go stand where Lincoln used to
stand in the back of the room and just
sit there and watch everything I do it
all by myself and this was the worst
time in American History Civil War and
you know he just he just kind of got in
the moment and I just went with it for a
second and man it was powerful and I'm
not a Kevin McCarthy fan I don't know
but good for him I think as an American
we're rooting for our politicians to
just get this [ __ ] together figure it
out if we learned anything from the
midterms it's like we don't want The
Fringe element whether it's on the left
or the right running the government well
here's the channel here's what happened
I'll give you my my cake and Tom video I
want to hear what you guys got to say uh
is the the challenge you saw between him
and everybody else was a couple
different things remember day after
January 6 he got up and he says the
president have to do this with a mask on
Kevin McCarthy called that Trump
hardcore day after January 6th I think
it's 7th or 8th when he did that you're
saying two years ago two years ago yeah
and behind closed doors he's been saying
a lot of stuff about a lot of different
people and and people have a memory on
what's been said and so what happens
when you're wanting this position and
some people wanted Jim Jordan and who
he's a guy that's a tough strong guy
that's not afraid of going after them
the only thing that he's got on himself
is the fact that he took money from
Google but a lot of these guys took
money from Google here's what happened
with this guy
he thought McCarthy he thought
two months ago three months ago this
shit's gonna be a red wave I don't need
any of Trump's people yep zero I don't
care what they have to say whatever Matt
Gates or this or this or that or
margarine you know Green Taylor and I I
don't know sir I don't know nothing
because it's going to be such a big red
wave the day it wasn't a red wave
of course well some says it was worth it
for Trump fine you know a lot of people
say it was the worst day for McCarthy
because the moment that happened
McCarthy sat there and said holy [ __ ] I
gotta go back these guys and I gotta
make deals if it was a Red Wave he
wouldn't have to make deals with nobody
so these guys went there you know what's
Wonder asks that they had the whole
negotiation why you won so many
different runs you know one that asks
was
term limits one of the ask close
terminal limits guess who doesn't want
term limits any of them there's no [ __ ]
the establishment house the guys that
I've been doing it for 20 30 years they
don't want to freaking agree on term
limits he wants to put term limits my
car so no no no not McCarthy does gates
and those guys are pushing for terms of
caucus guys yeah yeah the younger guys
so for me listen I think who came out of
it strong and I know this is going to be
weird because Bill O'Reilly's like Matt
Gates is going to pay price for this and
the next two three four five years and
he's going to do this Bill O'Reilly may
be right everybody may be right we don't
know the whole story what is evident
is that no matter how much people try to
say about
the the Trump Camp they did not win the
Red Wave and it hurt guys like him he
has to still figure out a way to have a
relationship with Trump in the in the
interim uh a lot of this stuff is taking
place right now where these guys gotta
figure out a way to get along you saw
him the next day where Matt Gates is
like well you know I just want to say we
are very happy and everything's gonna
you know we are we're going to be
working together we're going to be
unified we have to get this thing done
we have to do this we have to do that he
says look six weeks people took six
weeks off at the house what's the big
deal between us finishing it up on
Tuesday versus Friday and going four
more days there's nothing wrong with it
you guys took six weeks off yeah you
mean to them you can't wait four more
days so it did look like the Republicans
were divided publicly uh and then you
know maybe they're gonna figure out a
way to work together but this isn't
about Republicans and Democrats Adam
this is my opinion this is about the
guys that are part of the club who have
been in this club for 20 plus years and
it's the new guys coming up that are
actually doing this who have a little
bit of real vision and stuff that they
really want to do versus the other guys
are like oh shut up with your you love
America America is the greatest country
in the world be quiet let us do insider
trading let us do this let us do that
the guys that have been on for 20 years
cannot stand the newer guys because
they're making them work they never like
the newer guys that make the older guys
they're like the squad they're like the
squad they're like the squad the squad
they don't seen all those guys those
guys are knowing to Democrats
that's so that's their equivalent great
example that's exactly what it is you
said the Matt Gates and all these people
and from what I saw Adam it was just
like the Republican party you guys won
you guys don't got your [ __ ] together
and I get it there's all Trump and this
but it's like you uh a Democrat kind of
was in the running to get the the
speaker of the house like what do you
what are you guys doing you have this
great opportunity just like you said get
to what the hell's going on like this is
a moment where everybody could show like
working together that Unity stuff but
like you said to get those right to get
those establishment people out bro
they're you're not gonna budge those
people aren't moving bro they set the
rules so that they can have that forever
I don't know if you watch I'm pretty
sure Adam some of those Judiciary here
is where like Chuck grassy did they look
like they're 105 years old well Chuck
Grassley is 100 years old and it's like
bro those people are making decisions
the Joe Biden these people they're
making decisions bro and I love my
mother true death She's 75 when I talk
to my mother you could tell she's doing
fantastic that's not somebody that I
would be like Mom make a decision on
she's out of the loop when somebody's 80
something years old or whatever you're
we're giving 90. Chuck we're asking them
you're making decisions for right now I
just don't trust you and yeah there's
people whispering in their ears but come
on man we need that real change that's
that's the real change is let the
younger people come in there like just
like you say it all the time Adam put a
45 year old present in there did we see
that guy and just going off of that Adam
I'm I'm dead serious this week I'm doing
the Gavin Newsom pre-bet in Vegas I'm
not even joking that guy because he just
did something too bad he just he's doing
something presidential he just made a
comment Rob where he said he just said
something that got controversial stuff
about what's that I don't I don't know
what it was I think it was yesterday you
said something about
California something controversial and
they're like that's the that's the
candidate there's like three different
news outlets including Fox they just
said Biden's about to come out and
announce his candidacy that he's running
he's announced his run but he ain't
gonna run it's so it's like a low by the
way I hope he runs yeah me too I hope he
runs on the flip side it is embarrassing
that they even are allowing this guy to
go through what he's going through it's
embarrassing you know you know how you
know how um at the end of Reagan's uh uh
career what was happening to Reagan he
was having his um he had Alzheimer's yes
we had a relative who had a Brink who
had a a what do you call it a aneurysm
and he did not look good the last six
months of his life and this is a man
that's a very handsome what's going on
what are you what are you doing here you
want water yeah okay so there's this man
in our family good looking guy very
famous influential
unbelievably known in the Iranian
Community but when he had his aneurysm
it was not a good look on how for him to
be remembered the last six months have
you noticed that Michael Schumacher you
don't see any images of him their family
does a great job protecting his legacy
the driver yeah the Schumacher had a
terrible accident skiing accident like
he's pretty much he's not he's he's not
doing not not here he's on his way out
he's dead yeah he's just he's he's got
nothing and the family has done such a
good job protecting his legacy where the
only thing we remember is that face with
the red uniform right smart uh I I I I
think if Joe Biden's uh a father of mine
or a brother of mine uh uh his wife I
would sit there and I would say look the
Legacy you don't need a second term to
be president
your one term is your president
if you're like this right now the way
you're talking how the hell are you
going to be talking in 2027 okay listen
thank you Husband thank you Dad thank
you brother bro let's just kind of kick
it and let somebody else that's younger
go compete for your spot which is Newsom
and again I'm talking on the Democrats
I'm not talking about I want to so I'm
just saying on the Democrat side let's
go let somebody else go run but it's
time it's not uh there's a part but the
family's got to step in and say pops you
got it you got to kind of kick it right
so Pat why do you why do you so as
thinking as on the Democratic side what
why do you think that they're because I
mean he didn't announce it that means
they kind of want him to is that who
they want to go against Newsom because
he'll have you know it'll just be a
landslide or is it that they don't have
anybody else really to go against Newsom
who we know is going to be the front
runner we're not stupid let's see what
happens what happens with news you saw
you saw what Neil deGrasse Tyson said
yesterday it was very powerful what he
said yesterday I said what are
indicators of success okay and part of
the discussion about schools which is
writing a book on I really curious to
know what he's going to talk about with
the book with the new schools he says
okay four indications of success for a
kid one is great but that's only one of
four two is social how they are with
people we never grade that no one gives
a [ __ ] you were socially good yeah
you're probably socially very popular in
school but that's one of the two right
three is ambition hey the kid wants to
do something big with his life you know
what the fourth one was capacity to
recover from failure yeah okay do you
realize Newsom his opponent once asked
them a question that the stuff that he
did with his brother or whatever
whatever the stories that he has and the
way he handled it and you know Newsom to
get the criticism that he's got in all
these years and guess how he handles it
of course he's not a good person that
you would want to be best friends with
the Newsom is not on the list of you
want him to be a running mate that's not
that guy but for a Democratic candidate
to be a face the guy has access the guy
is over overcome negative publicity
attacks on him so many times he is
dealing candidate for the Democratic
side the ideal candidate is him believe
it or not the recall is the ideal
candidate for him to be a politician
that's going to handle a future
impeachment that nusa may go through in
16 years okay so so if you're looking at
it from that standpoint newsom's your
guy well Pat let me ask you a question
because I mean what we're talking about
is we talked about term limits and
everything like that in this capacity
but we're talking about people 75 plus
these are super senior citizens I mean
Chuck grassley's 97 years old Alan
Greenspan which is 97 years old former
chairman of the FED Biden's 80 Trump is
in his late 70s you know let's use your
dad as an example one of the wisest best
men I've literally ever met in my life
Father Figure he's 80 years old so
here's my question at what point is
wisdom and experience the deciding
factor versus you know old and out of
touch because I feel like in this
country you know we don't we don't
cherish the elderly or or you know our
grandparents as much as maybe in other
countries I feel like oh he's old get
them out of here where does that like
for instance you have a very close
relationship with your dad your dad's
not trying to run a company right now
he's 80 years old where does wisdom
experience knowledge all play in versus
being kind of old out of touch not
having it anymore oh I mean you're
you're a sports guy it's like hey
Michael it's time Kobe you shot 35 from
the field that's not good Rob your mic
is on you shot 35 from the field that's
not good okay you know this is not this
is a good time for you to walk who you
don't 20 years you know it's time to
step away right hey you know Albert
Pujols you cross 7 100 home runs if you
think you can do 20 and you're going to
play DH and you play 81 games to maybe
get to the 756 Mark I don't know the 765
Mark I think bonds got that number and
steroids has not been linked to you you
kind of went under the radar during the
steroids error go for it but just know
that's the role you're going to play
those conversations are the hardest
conversations to have but it's typically
a person tough enough to have that
conversation with that individual to say
look this is just not your strength it's
time you've contributed you've done your
part you're a great citizen go be your
grandfather your grandkids want that
time with you selfishly go tell your
grandkids your great grandkids some
stories that one day they're going to
write about in a book when they run for
office one day that's an important
Legacy it's no longer your job to go out
there and do this so for me you know the
younger person coming up typically has a
lens that the older person may no longer
have and not only that they don't have
that reason to want to prove a point
anymore the other person does
the person that's coming up has more of
a point to prove to say here's what we
need to do that's where we need to go
here's what we got to do there's a part
of that that you want somebody younger
but with wisdom counsel around that
they're giving you advice this is why a
lot of time when people retire at 65 70
years old what do they do they go get
five board seats why do they get five
board seats I got 50 years of experience
some free enterprise capitalism that I
can give you some counsel on what to do
in the insurance industry let me be a
board member be a board member but no
longer CEO correct the job of a seal
requires a lot of energy where you don't
get lazy and tired in the middle of an
issue where you say ah you know what
just give China exactly what they want
I'm tired we've been going back for six
weeks no versus a 48 years going to be
like no no no no I don't care if we go
nine more months we're not giving this
to you no no we're not doing this to you
what is wrong with this guy he's 48 with
a lot of energy the other one's 80 years
old and this one wants to go to sleep by
the way I think that was the perfect
answer especially the end of it where
it's like use the age and wisdom
to give advice give counsel as a board
member it might be tough to be the CEO
so so let me ask you let's use a case
example if you could pick one person to
to be in Biden's ear and one person to
be in Trump's ear who would that person
be go with me here who would that person
be and what would that message be to
Trump and to Biden in your opinion I I
don't know how effective he is today but
I think Biden could hear and get some
counsel from Jimmy Carter so I don't
think he's going to believe Clinton
whatever they say I don't even think
Democrats trust Clinton's I think they
always think there's a motive there I
think he will trust Jimmy Carter because
Jimmy Carter's got nothing to gain or
anything if he's still able to
communicate I think Carter would be
somebody good I don't even know if Obama
would be somebody good I don't think he
would sit there because Obama's always
got Obama still young and ambitious so
he may give kisses his wife maybe I
think Biden's wife would be like I don't
like what Brock just say forget about
what he said I think if Jimmy said it I
think he may listen to Jimmy I don't
know again I'm just speculating I don't
know we're playing a game yeah I just
had a very uh I had somebody over at the
house this weekend who was his right
hand guy at one point I'm not I'm
talking to somebody that was a former
mayor of a very big city the financial
capital of the world the American mayor
and we spend four or five hours together
this Saturday we have a lot of
interesting conversations together we
didn't shoot a video with didn't shoot
us and nothing it was just conversations
we had together
um I I don't know I don't know because
what what Trump has going for himself is
60 years in business
so many people's lives you may have
changed that backstabbed you so many
people's career that there were nobodies
you gave them a shot they work with you
and they use that on their resume to get
the next job to become and then they
turned their backs on you and they said
something you saw the clip you're like
wait a minute did you forget 17 years
ago you were crying in my office those
moments people remember like I remember
a guy named Michael and moth is crying
16 years ago we're in Granada Hills and
he says one day when I make it I'm going
to tell everybody you changed my life I
will never forget these late night
conversations till two o'clock in the
morning 10 years later he backstabbed me
and I'm like oh wow so so if I'm on like
a this level of what I experienced at 35
years old he did that to me what makes
you think what he's gone through so I
don't think he trust anybody I don't
think he trusts anybody I think the
amount of people he trusts is is
actually less than this well I think so
by the way by the way let me put it to
you this way let me let me rephrase the
statement trust and respect not just
trust trust I think he trusts a lot of
people okay
but trust and respect their opinion is
acting less than this but I think
there's one person out there when you
think deeply about it it'll come there
and I don't think it's Don Jr and I
don't think it's Eric but there is one
person out there I think he really
respects and he knows has his absolute
best in mind that's Ivanka you think so
yeah the relationship with his daughter
is the strongest of any of his kids and
she's always strong strategically but
then stays out of the spotlight
um you say oh you know Jared wants this
so that well as a power couple there's
some of that but I think he would listen
to us I think he would listen to it let
me ask you this because if he he is
running again obviously yeah Don Jr is
going to play a major role so is Eric
but Ivanka and Jared for that Jared
Kushner have already come out and said
we do we want no part of round three we
are at 2016 2020 took its toll on us
we're building a home in Miami you know
I know about that they they want no part
of this what what how much does that
play a role in your opinion
of not having her in his Corner this
time around I I think that's big and I
think if you take a look at Trump right
now that there's like a little
he could use some firmness on the
Strategic Rudder I think he's the same
guy but I think he could use a little
firmness on the Strategic Rudder I don't
think he would have had a particular
dinner with a particular guest unless
things were that we all know about two
months ago before Kanye Nick Fuentes yep
I think things like that if he had a
stronger Rudder you know what I'm saying
like a core around him hey Dad I don't
know if this is the way to do this can
you pull up the Vegas odds real quick by
the way we're having this conversation
about the presidency
I mean dude Ivanka maybe she's just
being quiet she's like I'm not going to
talk about this maybe she's thinking
about the future I mean I mean maybe she
could run sometime down the road bro you
wouldn't see that I don't see that
Ivanka Trump let me just throw something
crazy out there there's rumors of a 1400
Adam uh yeah here you know rumors or no
well go ahead go talk about what you
want well these are the odds yeah
everyone knows here on the show I don't
look at Pew I don't look at Quinnipiac I
don't look at ABC I don't look at Fox
Vegas polls be because they have money
on the line skin in the game they have
money to win or lose this is the numbers
I look at so Ron DeSantis the clear
favorite to be the president of 20 20 24
2024 Ron DeSantis plus 225 Trump at plus
350. Joe Biden slightly behind Trump at
plus 400 and then a steep cliff fall off
and then Look whose name is right there
you got Gavin Newsom kamalo I think has
no chance to meet Buddha judge Mike
Pence Nikki Haley Michelle Obama these
are all thousand two thousand three
thousand chances Glenn yonkin nobody
knows you The Rock's still somehow in
there and then you got just the fact
that Hillary Clinton's name is still in
there I'm telling you right now the the
gambling bet not the sure bet I'm
talking about just the BET where because
y'all Democrats say what you want they
know how to they know how to win when it
comes on this because put your money on
Gavin I'm gonna say this right now I'm
not rooting for Newsom whatsoever I'm
not either but let's go put some money
awesome yeah we'll 500 each I'm done
scroll up by the way it's 1400. okay I
say you guys put 10 dozen eggs on that
there we go ten thousand dollars
by the way nowadays [ __ ] go to the
blackjack table all in matter of fact
be a do use your quick uh math break if
I put 10 grand on Jasmine Newsome right
now how much do I win
140 000 no 14 Grand you said 10.
we put a Grant Pass so we put a g we're
gonna win 14. you know what that is 140
Grand that's a down payment on that
Rolls Royce
damn right yeah I mean it's actually not
a Bad Bet to be honest I'm not not even
a little bit however do it however let's
go to The Descent order can you go to
the de Santa the secret to the secret to
Ron DeSantis by the way the the folks
who sell rolls-royce's contact Adam and
Vinnie they're about to buy uh
Rolls-Royce they probably shouldn't buy
shout out to our sponsor this Saturday
Rolls Royce all right the secret to
Rhonda sent us a success ignore Donald
Trump and attack business instead
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has been
compared to former president Donald
Trump for his uh bagadocious personality
and his response to covid-19 pandemic
the centers mimic Trump style at a rally
in Sarasota by tossing baseball caps to
the crowd and claiming that his
leadership has been essential in Saving
businesses during pandemic the sugar
industry was probably more in Adam
putnam's uh than they'd ever been for
any politician says Peter
publisher of newsletter Florida politics
he was their Golden Child the santis on
the other hand has voted against sugar
subsidies as a congressman as one of the
state's most powerful Industries pounded
him with millions of dollars in negative
ads many funded by dark money groups the
Santa stuck back branding big sugar as a
major polluter and aligning himself with
Everglades Foundation a conservative
conserv conserv conservation group
co-founded by the billionaire hedge fund
manager Paul Tudor Jones who became a
major campaign donor okay so the
scientist strategy ignore Donald Trump
how long will that work I mean it can't
go that much longer I mean is getting
crunch time it's under two years well
until they both step into a real ring in
South Carolina or one of the primary
States I think he can do that until they
actually step into the ring by the way
can we just put something to bed for
once and for all officially here on the
PVD podcast what episode number is this
uh 224. can we just put this to bed Ron
DeSantis is running for president in
2024. can we stop with the charades
you're the leading candidate for
presidency of the United States the
whole charade of like well I'm committed
to Florida we'll see how it goes we're
past that when you've passed
Donald Trump and the current president
for the likely
for president so here's my question I'm
having trouble understanding can you
unpack that a little bit I'm saying that
Ron DeSantis is running for president
enough with the game and I forgot which
interview Pat that I saw where somebody
was like it's like going up what you
just said like he cannot this is that
you know that moment in your life this
is a he can't have a meeting and be like
all right Trump you be the president you
over no I'll be the vice president right
now is this is his presidency that that
is the strategy working I mean the
question is the following guys let me go
back to the question is the strategy of
ignoring Donald Trump here's the
question let's stick to the question
strategy how long will it take for you
to ignore until you have to attack
um I think I think one more year I think
one more year and it's he's gonna get
the gloves are coming off yeah I gave my
answer as soon as they both have to be
in a primary and they have to say
something to each other there's no I say
one year Pat one year then it's going to
be bow what do you think he's gonna say
what is the shot what's the first shot
fired from like the moment Kamala went
after biting in the debate everybody was
like oh [ __ ] yeah racist or the moment
I'm right here I'm right here
or the moment or the moment who went
after Kamala with the uh with the uh
yeah the moment after her campaign was
over that day right when she went after
her absolutely okay okay you're done
Ender Wings off you're off next week
eight people yeah okay so how and what
is what is he going to attack what is he
going to attack the Santa yeah what is
gonna I got it tell me I mean he has to
thread this needle because he needs this
he needs Maga country in his corner but
he also has distinguishes himself it's
kind of like the conversation we just
had about the CEO board seat guy it says
Trump respect thank you for your service
you've done amazing jobs at the same
time
you've created this climate in this
country where Americans at each other's
throat
I want to be the person that unifies
America thank you for everything you've
done your policies everything you stand
for amazing I'm with you in your corner
but America is looking for something new
and something fresh and I think I can be
that person so Maga I know you're out
there I know you love Donald Trump I'm
with you I'm gonna take on the leftist
and the wokis I'm gonna be there for you
dude that's like the last thing he's
gonna say what do you mean dude what
happened to you what did you have for
breakfast today like you got to stop
eating cereal I learned through this new
book Jenna is reading
tell me why I'm so wrong here because I
actually think I'm spot on Adam those
eggs were bad
he has to what do you think he has to
walk a tightrope between balancing Maga
but also winning a general general
population what do you think it's about
what do you think
I think uh he he has to to counter so if
I'm sitting with him with the scientists
with Rhonda centers I'm sitting there
saying instead of figuring out what
you're gonna say here's the 40 things
that Trump's gonna say
how are you going to counter on which
ones are worthy of counter which ones
you deflect and you just move on with
okay so what is one thing a hundred
percent Trump is going to say to
DeSantis here's one thing he's going to
say if I don't come and give that
endorsement he barely want governorship
without me he would never be Governor
right now Florida would have a
democratic so you're welcome Florida
he's going to say that okay okay you
would have lost to Andrew and by the way
by the way true just so you know it's a
story that's right yeah 100 he's right
okay
so that's 2016 though I mean it's a long
time ago it's going to be eight years
removed you could be right a hundred
years ago what's right is not about
history right is right okay hang on
that's right keep going so he's going to
say that and uh uh what's the
scientist's answer to that he has to say
I'm very grateful that you came out
you're right it was right so yes this is
the sentences right rebuttal me winning
the first election you had a lot to do
with it but me going from 34 000 Victory
to one and a half million that's me not
you 100 so that's powerful so that's how
powerful that he's got to go back and
forth I stood up to coved I responded to
this guess what the voter's gonna say
even Maga because everything's about he
needs to win the magazines he's not he
already has the Republican uh in his
vote but the mega vote the mag of vote
they're going to say it's gonna write
you know what I'm saying it's kind of
right he set up the Disney education he
responded to these disasters he kind of
did that yeah well listen everything
you're doing is pretty much the policies
that I would have done yeah for sure
he's just doing policy so he's kind of
like he's mimicking him copying
everything I did you know it's okay so
he's going to say well I give credit to
Great policies these policies those
policies these policies you were right
they were great policies what we did
different that you didn't do was this
policy this policy this policy and those
ended up working out in our favor but
yeah partially he's right there's the
policy they did right we were going to
duplicate and the ones we added here's
what we did okay but I've made this I've
done this I've done this so you don't
know what it is to do this you're right
I've never ran a multi-billion Dollar
business but the benefit I have is I
have proof to show that I was the
governor of the state that got the most
criticism over any other state in
America and I was the governor of the
state that stood behind parents stood
behind a mom stood behind homeschoolers
stood behind people that wanted a choice
stood behind those guys and we showed
that the right formula of how to react
under the pandemic the only the one that
led everybody else was the state of
Florida I get credit for that as the
governor of that state and that's given
me the credibility and a moral authority
to now run for office to be a America's
president so that's the second one then
he's gonna I mean he's gonna come back
what the scientist is not going to do
because the sentence is as much as he is
a very much of a counter you know what
do you call it counter puncher he he
also knows where not to go he's not
going to go family he's not going to go
kids they're going to try to get the
centers to talk about how do you feel
about the fact that the president's been
married three times he's not going to
say nothing they're going to try what do
you think about the you know the link to
this and link to that he's not going to
fall what if they bring up like how he
respond how he's gonna defend Trump
defend trouble okay he's gonna defense
right he's gonna defense right he is
going to defend Trump until it comes
down to him showing that I am my own man
got you that's what's going to happen
because because DeSantis is not a trump
mentored guy it's an indoors there's
those are two different things a
mentored requires loyalty and endorsed
is just thank you man I'm grateful I
appreciate you do you understand what
I'm saying the difference there's
there's mentor others indoors mentored
requires loyalty endorsed only requires
respect and thanks wow gratitude so the
sentence is not a dummy he's going to be
solid and Trump's going to play Trump
and uh I I uh I think
I there's no way in the world Trump's
all of a sudden going to turn into
saying this new guy that's not going to
go and do anything with them no the only
the only thing the only thing that
could happen is if the conversations
lead to something happening with the
court that it's going to be very very
very very
ugly then the census has a card yeah and
and you know what card that is what what
card is that if they go off the trumpet
I don't think you caught what I just
said are you gonna say it again let me
say one more stuff if notes impeachment
who gives a [ __ ] about impeachment if
they go after him court-wise Trump trump
yes you're unelectable not on the
election the classified documents if the
stuff is like because listen here's
what's going on with America man you
know all the [ __ ] that you're finding
about Elon Musk they're targeting him if
you try to Target anybody and use
billions of dollars of government
resources and lawyers you're going to
find something on everybody good luck
hey America we learned something today
all of you guys got some [ __ ] in your
closet that you're dealing with
financially they can find it okay if
they want to Target you they can Target
you they can Target must they can Target
everybody okay
uh so Trump is the second most hated man
in America today the most hated
president living alive today he's number
one
and if they go after him they're going
to find a lot of things who's got 50
years of History taxes records a bunch
of different things deals
he's going to need the p word
he's going to need the p word when
somebody becomes a president
protection no yeah I got a different
keyword okay pardon wow yeah if it goes
that route and it's just going to be
like my first position
one I'm pardoning this two let's get to
business and do what America needs to be
done okay no one's perfect here's a
pardon let's move on then he gets the
support then Trump can go golf and spend
the rest of time with us with his family
and all that other stuff again remember
what I said don't put words in my mouth
I said if the government keeps
investigating and trying to find [ __ ]
constantly over and over and over again
to make his life a living hell where for
the rest of his life he has to deal with
tax IRS [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
eventually going to be like listen man
just give me this I'm gonna go play golf
I'm gonna go hang out leave me alone let
me spend time my kids I didn't and I I
think this is going to hurt the
Republican party because think about Pat
you have these two Alphas that are going
to be at some point they're gonna lock
coins right I do think the scientist
could be a synergist you think so I do
think this sentence could be huge but so
do you think as a higher likelihood of
getting to this magic number I keep
talking about 60 approval rating Trump
or the sand the Santos is it even a
question no no not at all but what I'm
saying is I don't I don't solve for that
though but listen I don't that's an
indicator let me let me tell you
something you know
the the this guy like what what does
Trump truly believe in uh Trump no 100
and by the way capitalism by the way I'm
not even being a jerk by the way by the
way by the way just so you know you wish
you believed in yourself as much as
Trump believes in himself of course okay
yeah so don't ever judge a person that
believes in themselves as much as this
guy believes in themselves okay for a
guy to have the world after him and he
goes and golfs with pressure and people
making fun of him when he golfs and he
said did you see that drive did you see
how good it was did you get that are you
going to show that are you going to show
how good of a shot that was even with
you talking [ __ ] to me yeah there isn't
anybody in America today that can handle
the kind of pressure and hate and
mockery as that guy leaders bulletin
he's first on that list I'm with you on
that if I may there's a difference
between pride
and hubris be familiar remember we
learned all that in Greek mythology and
I think Trump is is is veering towards
more hubris Than Pride I'm you're 100
right we all wish we had the
self-confidence but it veers towards
hubris I may have lived a life that many
like if you want to like uh think about
a Great Gatsby type of a movie to see
who's lived a Crazy Life
I don't know bro put who's lived a
crazier life than a better life but he's
denying that you're absolutely right so
absolutely all I'm saying to you is if
if I want to have somebody go up against
Killers yeah dirty ugly mother you know
like legit people like that I'm sending
him let me ask you one more thing I'm
sending Trump I'm sending him if I if I
want somebody that's a
um
you know from like you know the other
day uh uh I saw a clip by Obama Obama's
like you know they say uh Barack uh you
know he cannot uh handle Putin and and
uh you know he is afraid of Putin and
they say things like this about me well
I mean if you're talking about you're
gonna handle Putin better than I will
my Canon my opponent you know the the
person that's saying all this stuff
about me he can't even know how to
handle CNBC moderators and then you hear
the cross ah yeah and then they show the
clip the first time Trump means Putin
and he pulls Putin in Yankton and you're
like whoa yeah that that guy's a former
KGB no and and Alpha is Alpha that was
felt within a second there is no
question there so the the point is if
you want somebody to go in places like
that to handle people like that
immediate
it's the other guy that's the most hated
president alive today but the scientists
is going to be the one that's gonna do
similar job
with lesser fewer controversy added
baggage all the other stuff that comes
with it and a smaller Target because
quite frankly he's not the personality
that Trump is he's not the Entertainer
that Trump is he's not uh uh a character
that Trump is but
he will make a very good president yeah
I think the centers will make a very
very good president I agree what do you
what do you think you know the saying
like uh Never Wrestle with the pig
because you get dirty in the and the Pig
loves the mud that whole thing went
because one thing we haven't discussed
is when Trump gets dirty all right Ron
sanctimonious there he is you know he
would be nothing without me we gotta
wrap up what what does the Santas do
Trump's get gets really dirty I I I I
don't think he's gonna go there and I
don't think Trump's gonna go there I
don't think DeSantis is going to go
there right I think the santis is wiser
than Rubio there's a reason Rubio's just
a senator he's not going to play that
card right and I'm I think Rubio is one
of the best speakers that we have he
makes a lot of good points and I think
it's a valuable voice but he's not uh
the scientist the sentence is Superior
in that area I don't think it's going to
fall for the Trap
I think the santis is very very very
sharp very sharp like very sharp he
ain't going to fall for it and he's
going to just go here he's going to go
here he's going to go here and you and I
are going to sit there and we're going
to watch and say man that guy took that
many shots at him all you've done is
give that man respect back
I have to respect you I think that's the
moment we're all gonna have at one point
let's you know I think before that
debate yeah so with Trump he's going to
be reading a lot of Marcus Aurelius both
of them they need the right people
anyways they need the right people in
their ears too but at least at least
it's gonna be yo we have a good we have
like a prize fight that's coming in in
like a year and just get ready for the
fireworks it's going to be great anyways
this is a great show today very good
show two hours felt like five minutes we
had a great time we learned a lot
um we're doing another Rob what's our
next thing are we doing a podcast
tomorrow or the next day was it Thursday
and then Friday do we have Thursday and
Friday we have special guests this week
right Thursday and Friday is going to be
fun uh have a wonderful day today if you
didn't get a chance to watch the nil
deGrasse Tyson podcast go watch it okay
if you don't find it for whatever reason
on YouTube you'll find it on Valentine
and you can find it on Spotify but go
watch the whole whole thing then tweet
me and tell me what your biggest
takeaway from that podcast with Neil
deGrasse Tyson was take care everybody
bye-bye